so i want to spend this time today
actually talking about a little bit
about the editing room because that's
ultimately where the everything comes
together so i'm curious you guys filmed
the
david is known as a
very meticulous person and very you know
hands-on i'm just curious if you could
talk about the editing process with him
and you know how the film possibly got
changed in the editing room
yeah um i mean he is meticulous and and
and so i was a little wary going in to
see what the collaboration was going to
be like and in fact for the most part it
was better even than it was on the show
and i
i diagnosed this to be that
i think david was at his most
controlling when he was doing the show
because he was kind of sequestered in
the writer's room and he kind of had to
feel like he had his hands on what was
going on out there because otherwise it
might go wrong
so i think in that way the show is a bit
more controlling
and the great thing about this process
was that he was with me we were together
we were collaborating so it felt like uh
in a way more freedom in a way because
he uh there was more dialogue going on
and stuff um the editing room yeah
that's where movies
are made or broken um i've had
experiences of both uh and we had the
strange editing process first of all we
had the greatest editor in the world
chris tellefson who's got an amazing
resume um but the weird thing was that
because of covid you know we were
shutting down and and starting up and
and so the
editorial process got really extended um
you know which can be a bad thing
sometimes because you can overthink and
and sort of spiral into uh
your mania um
to me that
there was a push pull between me and
david on
certain things um
i was really grateful that he kept
listening even when i was being uh
probably irritating um there were some
things i got
my way at the very late in the game
towards the end so that made me very
happy and very grateful to the way he
was working with me uh there's some big
ones that we disagreed on that he won
because if it really comes down to you
know me or him he's he's
he's going to be presented um
if it comes down to that you know he
gets to he gets to make the call but for
the most part it was um
it was good i probably like all movies
there's this kind of process where
you're really excited and then it gets
kind of dark and you're thinking oh man
we're losing in the editing room and
then you you know you you pull out of
the nosedive and it's better at the end
than you than you feared
well one of the things about this film
is it's unusual because you are not
doing the typical film of a typical
storyline where it's just one character
this is really an ensemble piece so i
would imagine you have you know you have
to balance all these different
storylines in the edit and also
realizing you only have so much screen
time to tell their story yeah um
absolutely that's partly the way david
writes is he tends to write multiple
multiple story lines that tend to sort
of interact so it's not the clear
beginning middle and and end of one
story uh
so naturally you know there's some
things that we lost from the original
cuts that i that i missed but that sort
of had to in order to bring a kind of
shape to these many stories and then
there was a kind of cool thing that
happened because because we paused for
covid david had a chance to do some more
thinking and he actually added some
things that we shot late in the game
that that are very important to the
movie now i think um
and
they were they they were all
improvements and i think we only got a
chance to do that because we had a
moment to pause and see what
the movie was looking like and then sort
of adjust from there
uh i have so many more questions but um
i'm gonna i'm talking to your team about
finding another time because i'm already
out of time today four minutes
uh i've and that i'm sort of like
getting off on your background figures
and your cyberdyne teachers and your
your ed 9000 and i mean you've got a lot
of things that
yeah
i'll stop here we're going to talk again
um and we'll go into more geeky details
um
thank you for your time today congrats
on the movie hope it's a huge hit talk
to you soon thanks
you